i'm i have to be selfish for a minute
and tell you i was a little emotional
thinking about doing this interview
because i'm not sure i've interviewed
you since the idol red carpets
when you and kade were like maybe
starting a date
and now you're a mom and nominated the
most
at billboard on sunday how does it feel
to have the most nominations to be up
for nine
awards how is that feeling to you
crazy it's overwhelming but in the best
way
if that makes any sense like this is one
of those things that it's really hard to
kind of put into words because it
doesn't really
feel real you know like when you work
for so long towards something and that
it actually
happens it's hard for me to kind of
switch gears because i've just been in
the mode of like
trying to get to these places of getting
onto the awards and getting the number
one songs and so now that you're
actually like
pitstop we're here we're making a stop
it's like
whoa so it's it's really cool oh the
female finalist with the most
nominations
if you had to pick one that you really
want to win
which one is it oh my gosh
i don't know i would say
oh my gosh i don't know they're all
really good
um
yeah i was gonna say best female uh
country artist
i think i would really like that one
would be really cool
but any of them would do but that would
be really cool
you've just been so true to yourself
through
the wild and crazy past couple years it
feels like to me
um how did it feel for you
for example like i saw this instagram
picture you posted and you said
here's my real life i'm doing laundry
i'm cooking i just did interviews
how what how grounded is you and kade's
everyday life still despite
being at these awards shows and
nominated in public figures
yeah it's uh i i just like to show
people on social media because you know
social media can
portray it can portray a lot of just the
positive things and the upsides and like
people's lives and things that kind of
just look
i don't know masked a little bit you
know like
not like the nitty-gritty of your life
and so
with me i just want people to know like
i'm not just this oh she's on this award
show
in here and there and it's like i still
hustle and bustle and do the dishwasher
every day and cook and fold and
try to live the life of you know finding
the balance of
of being a mom and entertaining and
just trying to balance everything out so
i think it's always fun
just to see like how people are actually
living behind you know being a performer
too
when you wrote the sweetest letter to
your little one on mother's day
how has being a mom changed who and how
his parenthood changed you and cade's
relationship
oh gosh um uh
a lot so like when i first got married
that changed me in a lot of different
ways you grow up in a lot of
different ways and then when you have a
baby you grow up in even more ways
in the christian faith there's a term
called dying to yourself
and definitely when you have a baby you
definitely learn to die to yourself and
everything's just about them and
centered around them and it and it's
actually really helpful because i think
i could
definitely become more um selfless and
and help
other people in a lot of different ways
and so her being brought into the world
has helped me so much in a lot of
different ways as a person and so it's
been
it's been neat to kind of see even
myself evolve in a lot of different
things
did you have a good first mother's day
by the way i did
i did it was very very very sweet and i
was like is this really happening am i
really celebrating mother's day because
i'm just so used to like telling
my mom like happy mother's day and now
it's now it was reversed onto me and it
was pretty cool
what did kate do so he got me a bunch of
sweets that i like
and set them out um and he was extremely
helpful with the baby
um throughout the day and then he he
made me a little bath and put like
candles and stuff there and it was like
the perfect
end to the day and i was like yes so
it's very nice
that's amazing um so you are
looking also at hitting the road again
soon right with thomas rhett
what's it gonna be like to a be
performing again
and b how will you handle it with kate
and the baby are they coming with you
what's the plan
yeah i'm really excited to finally be
able to hit the road and do some shows
um what it'll kind of look like i mean
we'll have a tour bus
and um have our own kind of home on
wheels
you know um which will be nice and
exciting um
she will definitely be with us i'm
really excited for her to kind of be
able to watch us on the side of the
stage and
as she grows become more aware of what
we do and
songs and things like that and then
eventually hopefully we can write a song
about her
and it'll just be and it'll just be so
sweet so i'm definitely looking forward
to getting to now experience
live shows and performances and all of
those things with her
with us so that's gonna be a musical
child she's got some good genes i know
i know she's a very lullaby baby right
now so she loves
music she falls asleep to like little
little music so i'm like
there it is there it is well billboard
on sunday we can't wait to see
you win them all um but is there anybody
else who you are looking forward to
seeing meeting maybe like
connecting with for a potential collab
we got nick jonas we got pink
tons of cool artists oh my gosh i i
honestly don't know i don't know who
i don't know who all i'm gonna end up
seeing i'm definitely excited to see
lots of people um that are gonna be
performing and i'm not sure how
everything's working
and all of that with you know covered
precautions and whatnot
um but i'm definitely excited to see
because all of a lot of the stuff that
i've went to is a lot of like country
music stuff and so i haven't really went
to anything that's like kind of all
genres across the board um so i don't
know
i don't know what we'll say pink's
getting the icon award i could kind of
see you and pink killing it
on a song together pink oh my gosh
that would be insane she's got some
crazy vocals
i will take that yes oh well i gotta
wrap with you girl but man it's
just final question it's it's it is just
wild to me you've done so much in the
past couple years do you look at your
life and did you have any idea you'd be
where you were
where you are now at this still this
young age
i had no idea this was gonna happen ever
since
kind of getting off of american idol and
just
hitting back at the ground and really
moving to nashville and
diving into everything and working hard
to get a record deal and
writing songs and really getting into
the community and everything i mean the
music industry has just been
absolutely wonderful towards me which is
extremely humbling i'm
very blessed um for that and i
appreciate it so much and everybody's
just been so kind so it's been
a crazy roller coaster past three years
i guess now and uh yeah it's crazy that
i'm here so i'll be flying on cloud nine
for
for a good bit married baby
billboard music award finalist so many